mr acarante sticks scalp leeches
i'm lost
hi i'm dr sammy ramsay sammy's an
entomologist i'm back today i'm going to
break down clips from movies and tv
about bugs we are including spiders
centipedes millipedes they're not
technically bugs but we do study them so
we're gonna include them today let's get
into it spider bite spiderman
while you can actually identify a lot of
organisms by the specific constructs of
their venom it is not them injecting
their dna into your body that's going to
wrap around your dna and change your own
genetic code that's called lateral gene
transfer doesn't happen between spiders
and people
i would like to dispel this myth right
now
the vast majority of spider bites are
not going to present as these two dots
on an upraised section of flesh on your
body that's impossible spiders tend to
have mouth parts that are really close
together if a spider did actually bite
you though rather than you expecting to
see those two very distinctive puncture
holes it would probably just look like
one dot that's because it's very
difficult to resolve just based on how
close together their calycera are makes
you think i would want to know that
who wouldn't
butterfly close-up spongebob squarepants
what you're looking at there is
hematopoda pluvialis and it is a type of
fly specifically the common horse fly
butterflies have a much more adorable
face totally fuzzy huge eyes they've got
this rolled up straw that's from two
different sections that are sort of
zipped together with a zipper-like
mechanism it allows them to reach deep
into flowers for most of these
butterflies that mouth part is
substantially longer than their body
but that is not even remotely the sound
that butterflies make butterflies are a
lot more graceful as they're moving
through the air kind of hang gliding
back and forth the sound that you hear
from those flies is because they are
beating their wings much more quickly
than these butterflies and that's what
creates this rumbling buzzing noise
morphological analysis the silence of
the lambs it's practically mush it's
found behind the soft palate of a murder
victim it may seem kind of strange that
she brings something from a murder case
to an entomologist but turns out this is
something a lot of entomologists deal
with on a rather consistent basis
there's even an entire field in
entomology that's called forensic
entomology let's check morphology
this was from a murder victim's body
no forensic entomologist is going to sit
around and do this kind of dissection
without gloves on secondly it's just
good protocol you don't want to
contaminate the scene
if i may uh they went a little bit too
heavy on the goo
so they end up opening this organism's
pupil casing it is a creature going from
a larva that has pretty much none of the
structures that it needs to be an adult
practically mush to an organism with
wings and eyes and you would expect
cutting open a pupa to find a good deal
of liquid
not at this point this organism is very
clearly a more mature pupa a lot of that
goo has already clearly coalesced into a
creature agent sterling meet mr
acharontia stixx
the morphological analysis here is spot
on when you're looking at the morphology
of an organism you're looking at all of
the odd bits and pieces the obscure
facets of their anatomy that all fit
together to make this creature the
unique organism that it is i only live
in asia asia somebody grew this guy
put him honey and nightshade so what i
love here is that they did get it right
that is a sphingid and that type of
sphingid acharontius styx is
specifically from asia they even got it
down to the food honey and nightshade
with the one caveat being they feed on
nightshade as larvae but they feed on
honey as adults and this one is still
transitioning into an adult it would
have never tasted honey by this point
hollywood loves to use swarms of bugs
so i gotta roll my eyes a little bit
with this because it has left people
with the impression that insects are out
for their ill that they're lurking
around every corner looking for the
opportunity to do something nefarious to
you and everyone that you love and
everything that you love i think if we
could just take a moment to recognize
insects have motivations that are not
even remotely foreign to our own they
want food the vast majority of them do
not eat people we see this with bees and
candyman
and in the swarm
so honeybees are legit vegetarians they
are not going to be eating people
chewing away at someone's rib cage and
we see this with moths in the possession
with the sheer number of tobacco
hornworm moths that she has in her room
somebody got some wacky tobacco around
there somewhere we also see this with
hornets in case 39.
his reaction to that was not overblown
cockroach sound and movement wally
the chirping noises are a bit odd
and totally unnatural cockroaches do
actually make noises and unlike most
insects they make noises to communicate
which is quite fascinating but for most
of these noises it's just the rubbing of
parts of their bodies together or
the movement of air through their body
being forced out under pressure creating
a hissing noise as you'll see in hissing
cockroaches
[Music]
something else that's also really
interesting in this scene is that you'll
see the cockroach seems to have the
ability to flatten and just be fine a
cockroach is able to flatten his body
because it is a thigmotactic organism
thigmotactic organisms love being wedged
between two flat objects so think of
things like bed bugs cockroaches they
like to wedge themselves in cracks and
crevices because they feel the most safe
when there's a flat thing touching them
on both sides of their body
they know that they are in an area where
creatures are going to have a very
difficult time dislodging them and
consuming them their heart their
digestive system all of it can flatten
quite substantially and this is the
reason why if you were to step on a
cockroach and then lift your shoe it can
just pop back up and run away
pretty crazy stuff
insect feeding
the fly how does brundle fly eat
brundlefly breaks down solids with a
corrosive enzyme it regurgitates on his
food it liquefies
and then he sucks it back up
that was actually pretty accurate it's
almost second nature
flies feed through a process called
extra oral digestion where as a result
of the fact that they cannot consume
solid matter they have to feed on things
that are fluids so flies have what's
called a sponging mouth part sort of
like a
a mop they have to regurgitate
some of their digestive contents and
bits of their last meal onto whatever it
is that they want to eat those enzymes
will break down this food into a fluid
and then they'll suck all of that back
up and that is how they get their
sustenance
what they gave you here was very viscous
very gooey not quite with the flies
there's not going to be as much color to
it it won't be quite as opaque so you
wouldn't notice it it's not something
that you're going to see looking at this
object to inspect for whether it has
been corrupted
that's disgusting living in harmony
james and the giant peach i'm a
vegetarian i eat dirt no one they'll be
eating you chicks yeah she'll just
puncture your head and suck out the
brain we're seeing a lot of bugs that
you would not expect to see all together
in the same place
while the insect world is all very
connected and really interesting and how
all of these facets fit together a lot
of bugs don't really live with each
other because
they eat each other
most of the creatures that they have on
screen are predators from the spider
even the glowworm the ladybug is a
voracious predator of other creatures my
life hangs by a thread every day so out
of this group of bugs the
spider would be the least discriminate
in what it consumed anything that it
could catch it would grab and eat bright
lights
big city that's where we gotta go the
centipede however would be running
around munching on pretty much
everything in the room such rude
behavior and the ladybug those guys
they'll just walk around and munch
whatever is in front of them
this particular ladybug is very clearly
representative of coccinella septum
pontada it's a species of ladybug with
seven spots and it is from europe and so
this axis that they've given her which
is actually pretty heavy on and off i've
had to send all 300 of my children to
safer pastures it's very clear that they
they went in the right direction with
her character that goes without saying
bee stings the wicker man oh no i love
the beast love the beast
i love my eyes
it's actually the case that bees tend to
be on chill mode most of the time but if
you show some level of aggression
towards them or something they perceive
as aggression towards their queen or
their babies they can get pretty hype
swelling in the neck region can
constrict your airways and can lead to
some serious complications this is the
reason why you'll see that a lot of
beekeepers will typically wear a veil
that comes down to protect the region of
their neck
[Music]
people seem to be under the impression
based on a lot of movies that insects
desire to cause ill to human beings if
you were to remove the hood with a bunch
of bees in it they're not all just going
to fly away as if oh we've done our job
everything is done here that's not how
it works and movies like this where they
lift the helmet off and they're like oh
is he passing out we're good now bye
doesn't really work out too well killing
me won't bring back your
money dino dna in mosquitoes jurassic
park
a hundred million years ago there were
mosquitoes just like today the
mosquitoes definitely existed during
prehistoric times life uh
finds a way mosquitoes are a lot better
at biting things than you would expect
people hear me say that they bit
dinosaurs and you think how are they
going to get through the height of a
dinosaur they still get through things
like crocodiles now oh there it is
parasitoid and host alien
okay so this technically isn't a bug but
we still need to talk about it
specifically because it is based on the
life cycle of a real insect there are
wasps ichnemonids braconids eupelmids
several different groups that are
considered to be parasitoids you may
have heard of parasites and gotten them
mixed up with the concept but parasites
actually don't want to kill their host
you are their house their incubator
their source of food they want you alive
and well as long as possible parasitoids
need to kill their host in order to
complete their life cycle
these are the stuff of nightmares there
are parasitoids that lay eggs in
caterpillars and the babies burst out of
the caterpillar's back in a pretty
dramatic scene and then spin a cocoon on
the caterpillar's dead body there are
others that are capable of controlling
the mind of their host such that even
though they've eaten away most of the
internal structures of that creature's
body they have left compounds in there
that control the behavior of the
organism such that it protects the
creature that killed it for the rest of
their animated life there are no
parasitoids that go after human beings
so you know you can rest easy at night
knowing that that is not something that
we have ever discovered in this world
touch it if you notice there everyone
just gathered around they were freaked
out you hear that oh god oh god but they
just kept watching
you got to document this stuff this is
observational data that we would have
lost had not sigourney weaver and her
colleagues stayed around and watched
what occurred there yeah i i cannot
guarantee you that if something like
that were to happen around a bunch of
researchers we wouldn't take a lot of
notes lice infestation the office
hey meredith i need to tell you yes
oh my god meredith what are you doing
baking a cake what does it look like i'm
doing getting rid of the lice you
probably won't hear this a lot
but meredith was right one of the best
most surefire ways to ensure that you
have fully gotten rid of the lice is to
shave your head because they do need the
hair in order to complete their life
cycle it's where they lay their eggs
it's what allows for a protective
structure for them they do not like
hanging out on just
naked flesh
take a picture it'll last longer but
it's a little extreme
because there are other ways you can go
about this if you just take a very fine
toothed comb to the hair and
consistently comb away all the lice as
well as their eggs which are called
knits this is where we get the term
nitpicking because it is very annoying
it's very time consuming but it does
work
scalp leeches skull vampires follicle
gypsies hair lawyers so
at the end of the day i enjoy telling
people that they shouldn't freak out
about insects insects are wonderful
creatures and they shouldn't be so
worried but
i also understand that you have to freak
out to your comfort level
actually
now that i look at it
it really looks like dwight has pulled
up a picture of a pubic louse here let's
talk cubes people i'm very confident
he's pulled up a picture of a pubic
lousy here i
hope that that's not what they have
running around in their head hair right
now cockroach habitat joe's apartment
[Music]
you can say what you want about this
movie but this jam
this is a bop y'all it's a certified bop
as revolting as this scene is they spent
time getting the texturing of the wings
for the cockroaches right the pronodum
is absolutely perfect this is very
clearly paraplenita americana they did a
great job with these cockroaches in
their morphological design he don't wash
he don't clean he don't vacuum you don't
give a crap he's the dirtiest freaking
slab on the planet
i think i'm in love i don't want to
perpetuate the stigma that if you see
cockroaches in your home you are a dirty
human being at the end of the day they
like food
and we as human beings love food so
how's about a live and let live
philosophy smoker
b-movie hey check out the new smoker oh
sweet that's the one you want the thomas
3000 smoker couple breaths of this
knocks them right out first of all we do
not use smoke to knock the bees out we
don't do that slice the nicotine all the
tar
this idea that we're all running around
spraying nicotine into colonies to get
the bees to calm down
we are not drugging our bees guys that
was a little weird there are some who
will actually use
leaves from tobacco plants they swear by
it that the bees are calmer under those
circumstances but it is not the norm in
the system
as you puff smoke into the colony the
bees think
is something burning maybe we should
just in case go and get as much of the
honey as we can move some of the honey
into their honey stomach just in case
they've got to do something else with it
later just in case they have to fly off
with it the other fascinating quality of
it is if you do get stung while you have
smoke in the air it is more difficult
for that stinger to signal to other bees
that they should come to that location
and sting you too because the stinger
releases an attack pheromone that
solicits more attacks from bees our
honey is being brazenly stolen on a
massive scale first of all male bees
don't lift a hand to produce any honey
in a colony if anybody should be
outraged about how honey is handled in a
colony it should be the worker bees who
are all
female members of the jury look at what
has happened to bees our bees haven't
been doing wonderfully lately and you've
probably heard about this
we have been losing between one-third
and sometimes close to half of the
honeybee colonies in the u.s every
single year it is concerning it is
disturbing whose side are you on the
bees mosquito bites jumanji we're fine
okay
we can't get through the glass
we're safe
the way that you see them kind of
pecking at the glass like a woodpecker
that's not how they do things that was
much more woodpeckery than it was
mosquitoey the mosquitoes actually have
these ratcheting needles that make up
their mouth parts that allow them over
time ratcheting back and forth to push
their way through the skin of an
organism
i would imagine that it wouldn't be that
difficult to get it through the rat top
roof of a vehicle especially since there
are all kinds of little gaps already
present that you can sort of push aside
as you're ratcheting that proboscis
through under the skin the mummy
all right there is no way that's
possible there is a substantial amount
of connective tissue involving quite a
bit of collagen that holds you together
such that organisms cannot burrow into
your body and just run around that way
even things like screw worms that do go
under the surface of your skin they
remain in that one place they grow and
they expand out the region where they're
living but they don't run around
[Music]
when you're looking at scarabs they may
look pretty fearsome many species of
scarabs have at least one horn a couple
of horns going this way or going that
way those horns are not used as a means
of defending themselves against
potential threats like human beings
those
well those are used in the process of
mate selection also the horns are
frequently used as a means of fighting
with other males to defend the lady that
you already have
chain of command a bug's life
the sun grows the food the ants pick the
food the grasshoppers eat the food there
is no chain of command
where
if the ants are not picking enough food
such that there is excess for
grasshoppers they are going to be beaten
up and have to have an uprising come on
it's a great story grasshoppers
don't store up any food because they
don't need to survive during the winter
they lay eggs that are capable that are
cold hardy enough that they're capable
of surviving the entire winter they
hatch in the spring and that allows
their life cycle to continue every
single year why am i even talking to you
you're not the queen
you don't smell like the queen that is a
really cool comment it makes me very
happy every time i hear it now that's
funny hopper is smelling the queen and
the best way to distinguish between the
queen and the rest of the individuals in
the colony is smell she releases just
this cocktail of chemicals that create a
pheromone that allow other individuals
in the colony to know the queen is
present she's learning to take over from
me hopper oh
i see under new management you see an
heiress who is being trained to be the
new queen that doesn't happen there can
be only one when it comes to queens they
release a pheromone that sterilizes the
rest of the individuals in the colony
you can't really have two queens at once
in the vast majority of ant colonies in
close proximity guys go shade someone
else for a while so it is an impressive
life to live but it is one where you are
constantly dependent on all the other
ants around you and it can turn on a
dime the moment that that queen is no
longer producing eggs all the rest of
the ants in the colony panic so then she
has to be replaced one of those
circle of life kind of things spider
attack harry potter in the chamber of
secrets hagrid never opened the chamber
of secrets
then you're not the monster no
judging by the distribution of this
spider's eyes and the ways that his legs
are
structured around his body it's very
clearly that they based it on a wolf
spider i cannot deny them fresh meat
when it wanders so willingly into our
midst
so it
doesn't quite make sense considering
wolf spiders don't have social
structures in which they hunt together
you get this many wolf spiders together
and eventually you just end up with one
really big really full wolf spider i
think not they do eat each other they do
seem to very much enjoy cannibalism for
a lot of spider species it just doesn't
really pay to invest heavily in
sociality
when you are social you have to be
willing to share resources
you can make a web
that allows you to easily capture food
without putting in much of any work you
can just walk over and eat it goodbye
working ants a bug's life
i'm lost it's actually pretty accurate
that ants follow each other that they
need to maintain connection with the
other ants watch my eyes but it's not
through a line of sight they don't need
to see the other ants in order to
continue trailing behind them it's
actually through a set of chemicals
there's a chemical trail that each ant
is laying down
as more ants lay down this chemical
trailer becomes stronger and stronger
and that makes it easier to follow the
ants to the next location and here's the
line again
thank you beehive piglets big movie
in order to be a bee
you've got to have six legs
and these guys definitely have four so
hmm
it's a little uh questionable as to what
we have here you know bees are sneaky
like that they actually look a lot more
like european hornets the the head and
the thorax is typically how european
hornets look and then the the striations
on their abdomen the the yellow and
black alternations that you see there
also pretty characteristic of your
european hornets did you hear something
i'm afraid i've got some honey in my
ears and
it makes a lot of sense hornets don't
make honey if anything what you have in
your ears is van vespa amino acid
mixture
it is actually this fluid produced by
the larvae of hornets now hornets are
fascinating creatures in that as adults
they're vegan actually they consume only
nectar from plants and the fluid of some
fruit and sometimes tree sap when they
collect other insects when they chop up
other bugs or collect meat they feed it
to their offspring who have jaws that
allow them to actually be able to
consume solid matter they have a
digestive system that allow them to
break down those meats and then they
produce this amino acid mixture that is
actually really really potent apparently
quite healthy stuff oh there is nothing
better
multiple studies now have shown that it
can be really helpful for keeping
muscles uh very active very healthy it's
sold in some countries as a supplement
robert will lure the bees with beautiful
music
then your attempts to bees into their
new hive
winnie the pooh movies typically have
the colony being this bunch of golden
lumps that are hanging from a tree
branch and that is how these colonies
are typically depicted in most movies in
most representations even in artwork and
it's just not accurate it's just a
drawing in a scrapbook one of the
reasons why this happens is because
colonies used to be kept in something
called sceps they were these baskets
that look exactly like the things you
see hanging from trees and i don't think
that enough people have recognized that
those aren't natural people wove those
baskets and put the honey bee nest
inside of it great new hive
eating bugs snow piercer
so they discovered that the bars that
they were eating are actually bugs and
i'm pretty good with that actually i eat
them too you know i think that we need
to be quite realistic with the way that
our world works we are on a planet right
now that is careening towards climate
disaster the the meat that we choose to
consistently eat and eat very very very
very frequently is from animals that are
not very efficient processors of the
food that they consume but insects are
they are really good at processing
crickets are six times more efficient at
processing the food that they consume
than cows medium rare now
there are some caveats here
insects have chitin in their exoskeleton
and as a result of that if you are
allergic to shellfish the protein that
typically triggers those allergies are
the same proteins that would trigger
those allergies if you were to eat a
cricket if you were to eat a meal worm
no way
there are several insects that are
chemically defended in the insect world
it is
considered proper etiquette for you to
signal to other organisms that if they
eat you they would die or at least be
very very unhappy about it and so there
are warning colors it's called
apisomatic coloration black and yellow
black and orange alternating or black
and red signal to other creatures if you
eat me
it's not gonna be a good day for you fam
brain sucking bugs starship troopers
[Applause]
[Music]
so that was upsetting
there are no insects that do this i uh
don't feel like i need to do any
defending of what you just saw there on
screen
like that just it doesn't happen bugs
don't do this but they've been rumored
to for quite some time i don't know how
i know but i know there was an organism
called the earwig for which a lot of
lore would revolve around this creature
crawling out of your wigs at night back
in the days where guys used to run
around in powdered wigs all the time the
idea was that the earwig crawled out of
your wig at night and burrowed into your
ear and laid eggs and fed on your brain
they sucked his brains out turns out
they don't do any of that they just live
under rocks and eat to try to you know
dried up dead leaves and things of that
nature
it's also really difficult to get in
there it's a whole set of apparatus in
place to keep stuff from getting into
your skull and eating your brain it's
it's um it's actually far more difficult
to do than these movies would make it
seem big
conclusion regardless of how hollywood
portrays things the most important thing
that you can bring to any of these films
or movies is curiosity and skepticism
there will be things that will look too
strange to be true sometimes they'll be
real a lot of times they won't be so be
willing to do your own research and
don't let that curiosity die stoke it
keep it going thank you so much for
watching
[Applause]
[Music]